[Musique]
on leur dit quoi au sujet des voyages
j'ai pas envie de froisser petit mot
d'ordre politiquement correct ça
évidemment
évidemment elle a juré alors j'ai
beaucoup d'énergie c'est déplaisant à
des pays a besoin d'aller si loin fait
un petit tour par barbes et puis city
flip comme on dit chez vous c'est du
second degré moi ça m'a fait rire je ne
supporte plus le politiquement correct
et suce boules un jour suce boules
toujours ce que je voulais dire par des
paysans c'est qu'on n'est pas envahis
par le tourisme de masse comme en
tunisie ou au maroc
ah oui nous quand on a visité la
cathédrale d'alger d'où t'es tout seul
mais seuls rien de tel que notre beau
pays
pour apprécier la douceur de vivre il
s'en passe tolère de bouge je revis
n'est quand même très manga this le bris
comme moi j'ai du mal avec la france et
avec odile on a décidé de s'installer en
israël
ç'a vraiment on part en chignon en
algérie par ah bon mais les à bombay de
quel rapport y faire carrière à
bollywood le pays où les gens sous
prosterne devant les vaches c'est la
solution
le gendre n'aime plus la france on va
leur faire aimer la france décidément
vous famille nous réserve toujours de
belles surprises
et qu'est-ce qu'on a encore fait au bon
dieu claude rien j'en sais rien on va
tout savoir à l'accouchement de l'or ont
trouvé leur n'accouche pas la tâche pas
si les noirs comme installer c'est vrai
qu'ils et puis évidemment
le saosnois et plus fort c'est la
puissance africaine
c'est très très noir quand même alors
s'interroge non pas du tout je fais moi
même si c'est simplement qu'il l'aurait
très blonde et que je pense avec les
tamouls tard c'est juste un constat ici
et en bon on a encore le droit de
constater dans le pays oui alors je
constate